des migrants accueillis dans les
yvelines la décision a été confirmée par
le préfet les maires du canton du
chesnay incluant bougival la celle saint
cloud rocancourt et louveciennes ont
appris la nouvelle vendredi matin ils
ont tenu une conférence de presse pour
exprimer leur position face à ce plan
d'accueil à rocquencourt
une centaine de migrants sera accueilli
pour une période maximale de deux mois
sur le site de l'inria
on est mis devant le fait accompli et il
est évident que rocancourt déjà 100
migrants dans une commune de 3200
habitants
ça représente 4% de la population et on
estime que c'est déjà beaucoup et qui
sera difficile de de cohabiter de son
côté l'ancien hébergera de façon pérenne
100 à 200 personnes
une situation problématique pour la
commune en effet de l'amiante aurait été
détectée sur le site situé lui même
proche d'une discothèque
en plus de cela un projet d'aménagement
avec des entreprises devrait voir le
jour sur ce site de ville vers un lieu
inadapté pour recevoir autant de
personnes selon le maire si c'est pour
reproduire ce qui s'est passé à calais
ça j'y suis totalement enfin d'arc dans
la danse dans l'esprit j'y suis
totalement opposé en tout cas je suis
fermement opposé à l'installation d'un
camp enfin à caen deux migrants sur le
site de villevayre que ce soit 10 que ce
soit sans les problèmes de sécurité sont
les mêmes
les deux maires opposés à ces
implantations obtenu du préfet qu'un
groupe de travail de concertation soit
mise en place
le plan d'accueil nécessite 400 places
sur l'ensemble des yvelines nous avons
jusqu'à je dirais fin octobre pour
éventuellement trouver des solutions
d'accueil de ces personnes si nous ne
trouvons pas la solution on nous
imposerait la solution de lucian
l'immigrant pourrait arriver sur le camp
provisoire de l'inria rocancourt dans
les jours qui viennent
concernant l'ancien l'échéance est
prévue fin octobre début novembre
du côté de la population la colère
gronde une pétition a été lancée par la
ville de louveciennes celle de
rocancourt a déjà obtenu 1300 signatures
en quelques jours